hey i'm steve harvey steve is a very
successful guy
steve is very successful made a lot of
money that's true yeah if
i could make myself successful
i would have done it a long time ago you
may know him
for his comedy you may know him for his
mustache
but today i want you to know him for his
religion somebody shared this with me
and i just i just couldn't resist
commenting on this video because it's
our old friend also steve
harvey i know steve harvey he's a
tv talk show host an author comedian
and he is i believe in dubai and he's
visiting a mosque and
let's see what else steve harvey has to
say
today i want to tell you about a guy
you may know him for his comedy you may
know him
for his mustache but today i want you to
know him
for his religion hey i'm steve
harvey stand up comedian entertainer
television host family man
but most importantly i happen to be a
man of faith now let's stop right there
you see a mosque this is a house of
worship a house of god if more
non-muslims not yet muslims and
obviously not yet muslims because
everyone has the potential to submit
their will to the creator of the heavens
and earth that's what a muslim is
and steve harvey he's wearing this is a
cultural thing so he's behind
a in front of a house of worship house
of god this is where muslims go
to pray to the one god the same god of
jesus moses abraham and
all the messengers that god almighty
sent they prayed like
like muslims pray in this mosque you
know you could pray outside the mosque
in the mosque but it's
more rewarding in the mosque where you
all you come together so we encourage
people to visit maas just like he did
and you see him dressed this is one
stereotype if you're muslim you don't
have to dress this way this is
more of a way that they dressed in dubai
you know he can just
continue being a muslim and uh if he
chooses to because it's open for
everybody just like malcolm x muhammad
ali and kunta kinte and
you know all the other african americans
because this is their roots actually
is islam so if he chose to submit his
will steve harvey to the will of the
creator has an earth
he can continue to wear his fancy suits
let's continue on steve
is a very successful guy he has made
more money steve is very successful made
a lot of money that's true yes famous
than he ever thought i'm assuming that's
his wife look i'm assuming that's his
wife look and she's
she's mashallah she's wearing the hijab
i love to ask her
how does your wife feel in that look at
that because she's look
um we're muslim women are commanded to
observe the hijab and this is
this is in accordance what uh jesus's
mother
mary look there's a whole chapter named
after his blessed mother named maryam in
the quran
and you have his mother also wore this
so any
picture that has been put out there
trying to
replicate what she might have looked
like she's also wearing this hijab so
next time you see a muslim woman in
hijab
you as a christian or anybody you see
that look she's imitating
mary the mother of jesus specifically
for christians here just think about
that and she's wearing that this is this
is amazing
closer than ever why
did you not lose faith as you became
more successful
if i could make myself successful
i would have done it a long time ago
i would have skipped so many of the
lessons i had to learn
but it's not that it's a process
success and happiness is a process man
and in this process i was
very aware of the amount of faith that
was needed
and as a matter of fact
it really took more faith than i even
thought i had he's it's good he's
attributing his success back to allah to
the creator
people god almighty that's the lesson
for us we can't ever forget that because
people become arrogant it's wrong
there is only one way to god
but steve's faith is unique because it's
really
not about that there's no one
one way to heaven no one way to paradise
it's like television now it's over 800
channels of cable
and they're all pretty entertaining so
i'm pretty sure man that to get to
heaven
let me stop right here i mean that
sounds nice that sounds good i mean
and for him also someone is a celebrity
famous you know
uh this is like what people want to hear
but in reality
we have to look back at the evidence we
have to be sincere we have to be
open-minded we look at
is this really what god almighty you
know he
ordained that you can come to him in any
which way i mean just
from a logical perspective just in life
right uh
is that how it works i mean people if
you're the boss and they can just
complete the project in any which way
you know you have you can just show up
at any time you want to work
you can just wear whatever you want to
work you know come in your bikini
come in your uh daisy dukes to work
right you can cut
i mean just in any which way there are
rules in society and they're also
because some people say look i don't
want to follow an organized religion
right but then would you prefer a
disorganized religion a disorganized way
of life and then you would attribute to
the creator
disorganization and being unwise and and
all these things that now we wouldn't
attribute to ourselves
so there is a way but we have to find
the way are we sincerely
as a christian which he is he's actually
going against
because it's the only way to have it
this is with all due respect
as a christian steve harvey knows that
look to come to god you have to
according to christianity you have to
believe in father son holy ghost trinity
uh the death and resurrection of jesus
christ but here in islam submission and
i'm sure
this would captivate him interest him
and be more of the natural incarnation
that he would incline towards
islam is showing that no no no you don't
have to go through a lot of these
illogical processes
processes that are not based on proof of
evidence but we have evidence
that god almighty throughout time he
sent the way and that way was to submit
your will entirely to the will of the
one and only creator of the heavens and
earth and every we say allah
and jews and christians were arabic
speaking they also say allah and you got
to probably
learn about that while you're in dubai
uh steve harvey
but we have to be genuine and we have to
sincerely
do what god wants us to do on his turn
because it's not burger king have it
your way and that's
this philosophy like you just do it your
way and then
it's gonna be accepted by god that
doesn't work and that's not how it is
so you got to submit your will to the
will of the creator of heavens and earth
and this is islam and a muslim is one
who does that
and you have to obey the messenger that
was sent at jesus time it was
it was jesus you couldn't bypass him he
was the way the truth and the light
moses time it was him he brought
revelation
and the evidence that he was a messenger
you have to obey him today is this time
for steve harvey
uh harvey for anybody it's the last the
final messenger prophet muhammad
he is the one the last and final
messenger we don't worship him
we don't worship jesus but we follow
their way the way they practiced
that submission the way they perfected
their character
the way of morality everything was laid
out there we have it today
in the quran and the example of the life
of prophet muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him and in the quran god
almighty is saying that whoever chooses
other than islam submission to the will
of the creator never will it be accepted
of him and in the hereafter he'll be
among the losers and prophet muhammad
said look whoever hears the me
and denies me look rejects me then that
person will find a place
for them in the hell fire look so we we
this is the evidence we have to present
it in the best way and we're trying to
do that so let's continue
on here with our friend steve
harvey there's got to be more than one
route because somebody watching another
channel are taking another channel than
you
they still getting entertained and they
probably still get into heaven
that's wishful thinking i mean they're
probably still getting to heaven that's
human beings you might you know you you
think you're going to get a certain car
or you're going to get a certain
position or some money just by
wishful thinking it's like you know
money's going to fall out of the tree
trees or whatnot
but there's a process you got to work
all right you got to work for jannah for
paradise you have to do good deeds you
have to have the right faith
but at the end it's ultimately by god's
mercy and god's grace
but it's according to his will not our
desires that's the main thing that's
equals islam
this isn't just stock steve lives
by these words he has three sons
two of them he gave them christian names
like broderick and one of them he gave
a muslim name ali as a sign
of respect and appreciation for the
muslim religion
and the muslim culture i named him ali
because
i knew i knew that that was very nice
that he might be different
and you have no problems with it he
named his son ali
because when you come here you
understand islam is a religion of peace
why you got a problem with peace it's
this is one misnotion that people have
that islam just means peace no it means
peace
acquired by submitting your will to the
will of the creator that happens in
earth
belongs to people and that's how you get
peace in life truly that's how you can
contentment by doing god's will that
pretty much means doing it
on his terms not your desires remember
that it's very important
a mosque with the name jesus on it
yeah the world could use a little bit
more of that i never really
understood exactly what i was doing i
had a feeling about it
but now when i look at this name right
here
and it says mary the mother of jesus
mosque
uh it kind of gives me a little bit more
of the understanding maybe it was
something i didn't quite know at the
time but now it's
starting to make a whole lot more sense
and steve it'll make even
a lot more sense look engage with islam
look just by this known fact now
that we love jesus as muslims we love
jesus
not as a god or a literal son of god we
ask people what do you mean you know
cats have kittens
dogs have puppies cows have calves what
do you mean god
had a son a baby god doesn't make sense
and there's no evidence for it in the
language of the
the bible you know because the bible has
sons by the tongues but metaphorically
that's different we're all the children
of god but to have god have a
literal son that's not what it meant at
that time nor does it mean
at this time we are all the servants we
are
all the creation of god almighty and you
are amazed by that
that we love jesus and his blessed
mother
imagine if you now engage and you got to
know about the pure monotheism in islam
and you'll be able to make sense of the
way that god almighty wants you to be
upon islam if you were to look at the
evidence and you will look at the quran
sincerely humbly just read the quran
since you're already in dubai
and your already wife is wearing the
hijab and you're already
excited about few of these other things
imagine if you were
even to engage more and you were to
learn a little bit more
imagine of the doors of of
of of blessings and mercy that would
open and at the end of this life
we know that anyone who truly submits
his will to the creator that heavens and
earth lives
on god's terms obeys god truly
not according to his desires but
according to how god wants you to live
all right not our wishful thinking then
paradise paradise is in store for them
more of these mosques many many more of
people like steve open up the mosque
yes we can agree with nas there open up
the mosque have open houses that we do
that open up the mosque have open houses
invite people like steve harvey and
others your neighbors so they can sit
ask those tough questions there's so
many different
misconceptions about islam islam is this
islam is that people talking about islam
but not getting truly
the opportunity to get to know islam to
get to know a muslim to connect
to make the human connection so i wanted
to make this short
quick little video and respond
and give my reaction i like when you
guys send these in it's kind of uh it's
kind of nice so continue to send
some of those videos that you like to
see me talk about discuss
and inshallah we can try to do that
thank you very much and for steve
harvey hopefully we can get you on the
dean show one day and we can discuss
your journey there
and inshaallah we pray that you look
into islam read the quran
and i always give this homework ask the
creator of the heavens and the earth god
almighty allah
ask him for guidance say guide me guide
me guide me if these people are in the
right way
this is the way that i need to be out on
that will get me to your pleasure and
your paradise put me on that road that's
the road i want to be upon
because we can go ahead and make up like
people do they make up their own
religions their own ways but at the end
it's not incumbent on the creator to
accept that it has to be on his terms
not our desire religious respect
religious
tolerance is the most important thing
and we need to promote that every
single day share religion share the deen
sheriff caring is sharing and we need to
be respectful
in a respectful kind dignified way we
can agree at the end to disagree and we
can still
live in peace and harmony thank you very
much subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification
bell and support us on our patreon page
we'll see you next time here on the d
show peace be with you assalamu alaikum
you